it has gotten to the point where it
tastes like spoons of sugar today we're
having over 100 Evan kick cats I'm gonna
try them all and tell you which one is
definitively the best flavor of KitKat
last time I had too much food I tried
every item on the McDonald's menu that
was very difficult
oh wow oh gosh this is a lot of candy
wow this guy's pumped this one smells
Walker's mmm Wow
really tastes like tangerine but there's
no chocolate no this is a vampire
it says handed talk why did why is that
the only English they gave me I don't
look favorite this is oh come on vanilla
remember when you're 12 me to go to the
dentist and they give you strawberry
fluoride
it's strawberry fluoride good cat I'm
going for one of these single ones these
are Kit Kat fancy this looks like a tiny
energy bar mm-hmm tastes like you think
a plant
all right let's try Barry oh it smells
like hockey Wow
[Music]
hey melon tastes like watermelon
bubblicious cookies and cream they taste
like a treat you'd get a Christmas open
house and a fat rooster that looks to be
two pieces of toasted bread with beans
in the middle how many ever had
sixteen or seventeen not ready this
one's boring solutions called amazing
music amazake oh wow it smells
immediately like alcohol kind of burns
like alcohol burns Oh God Oh sour oh
whoa what is that lemon
oh god it's great it's purple as we all
expected well it's not bad cognac and
grapes
it tastes like Jewish wine this is a
nice bright green maybe a lime maybe a
mint so it was sabe I actually kind of
like this shouldn't shoot apple smells
like green Jolly Ranchers a strawberry
maple strawberry maple sounds like what
happens when they you cute girl from the
South Mary's a Canadian [ __ ] no maple a
nut job right nipple no strawberry
okay you gotta up your game this is a
different package sake one so I'm
assuming it's gonna be good right oh
really
you know like you're not in control like
your brain is like doing stuff without
your conscious brain knowing it keep
like I'm going to put this in my mouth
and my hand keeps stopping short of my
phone
[Music]
mm that was the one this is inspired by
chocolate Ori sounds like a chocolate
purgatory I don't know if I can keep
going anymore well this is fun I didn't
need them all but I think I tasted all
the different flavors and in terms of an
answer the this matcha the shakku arai
matcha is the best one I will see you
next time on Keith's ruins his stomach
as you just saw Keith Denny actually
finished the challenge so I thought that
I'll Surprise them with more cake cuts
that he has to finish by the end of the
day hey why don't I give you a second
chance just have to finish the rest of
it I just finish what I didn't yes how
many is that that's 48
see you later joy oh [ __ ]
look at this really delicately
[Music]
nice all pile is in the way / hope you
enjoy the video
[Music]